こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
（バンッ）
声が治らないすよ
あのふざけてやっている訳じゃないですからね
低い声で喋ったら全然しゃべれます
低い声で喋ったら全然しゃべれるんですけど（大事な事なので２度）
ちょっと声を高くしちゃうと裏返ちゃう訳なんですよー⤴️
ふざけてやってないんですよ
高い声だすと声がひっくり返えっちゃう
ちょと風邪でね体調も悪いので
今日はちょっと早めに動画をとります
頭
頭とかもちょと痛かったんですけど
もうちょだいぶ頭の痛いとか収まってきたんで
あとは今度喉だけ
喉だけがちょっとおかしいので
早くの喉の方を早く治して行きたいとおもっております
（ははっ）
俺これ何やってももう面白いな
何しゃべっても面白い
もうしばらくこの喉におつきあいください
というわけで今日は
この今の僕にしかd
（げっ）
（うへっ）
この今の僕にしかできないことをやってみようと思います
今回用意するのはこちら
（かっん、かっんたたたたたたたt）
こちら！
ヘリウムガス
メガジャンボ
11.6L
日本国内生産安心ですね
声が変わる
ヘリウムガスを準備しました
もーやることは皆わかるだろ
そう
今の俺は
声がひっくり返ってるんで
普段の時の声より４オクターブぐらい高いんすよ
声が４オクターブ高いってことは
この
普段ヘリウムガスをして上がるレベルのヘリウムガスのガスの高さより
もっと高い声まで声が上がるんじゃねぇかと思いまして
僕が出せる声の限界の高さに
今日は挑みたいと思います
僕なかなか風邪引かないんで
こんな機会ないと思うんすよ
めったにない
すごいレア
この動画を見てる皆さん
高評価
今しかここで出来る機会は無いと思うんで
実際にヘリウムガスを飲んでどんな声になるかやってみようと思います
ではいこう
こちらがヘリウムガスお値段なんとなんとドンキーホーテで
なんとなんとなんと950円
950円でございます
（とぅるるっとぅ、とぅるるっとぅ）
（夢のジャパネットはじめ）
ふーーーー
はあああああ
プッフ
はぁー⤴️
あー
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
変わんねーじゃねいかー
はああ
あのー
特にオチはないっすね！
（番外編　キャップの巻）
はー
キャップが開かない
あれ、マジキャップ開かない
あ、戻った
え？キャッ
キャップ開かない
待ってヤバいガチでキャップが開かない
カン×11
えーヤバいヤバい
ヤバいヤバい
待ってヤバいどうしよう
カンカンカン
カンカン
マジヤバい
（カンカン）
痛っ
（シュシュ⤴️）
OK